Google l'a précédemment humilié
et a explosé son égo, et il revient aujourd'hui plus fort que jamais
Eh yo yo yo google t'as cru que t'étais qui frère
*Google Grande-bouche* AIE non ça fait mal Squeezie arrêteeeeee !
Ok yo tout le monde c'est squezzie aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur *AIE* d'accord !
Aujourd'hui on se retrouve sur The Higher Lower Game , la dernière fois souvenez-vous, on devait deviner les recherches les plus fréquentes sur google, on a été des énormes Mer***
aujourd'hui on doit juste deviner quel thème intéresse plus les gens que d'autres !
Voila c'est un resumé de mer*** comme à chaque fois !
Peter Kay a 74000 recherches mensuelles ! ... Et Burbery en a plus batard  !! Bouuuum *POOOOO* ! On va pas se laisser faire mon pote !!!
Miley cyrus combien elle a ? Plus de 1 500 000 bien sûr que oui! *POOOOOOO*
Le changement climatique en a-t-il plus ou moins ? Bah c'est hyper triste mais je suis sûr qu'il y en a moins... Puta** !...
*British Airways* bah c'est plus à mon avis que 246 000 à mon avis ! Puta** mais l'ironie ! Changement climatique 240 000, une put*** de compagnie d'avion fait 3 millions!
Euh... est-ce qu'il y a plus de 3 millions 3 pour des Dyson ? AAAAAAAh...
Ouais !...!
On est bon, on est bon Puta**
Ça vous voyez? C'est un esprit de revanche, de compétition !
Justin Timberlake y en a plus c'est sûr! *OOOH*
Alors tu dis quoi de ça Google , Hein ?! Tu veux que je te rende visite ? La rue de Londres à Paris, tu crois que je sais pas où t'habites?
Ils vont envoyer des vétérans pour me tuer !
Je ferais plus jamais de page d'accueil sur Youtube, c'est fini ! *RIRES*
Truman show ! Est-ce que ça a plus que Justin Timberlake ? Non...
Voilà, on est bien!
Jim Carrey, un peu plus?
*ATTENTE* Ouiiiiiii !!!
On a tout bon, on est hyper forts
L'homophobie? Hein chers homophobes, je crois que ça fait plus ???
J'suis une m****, j'suis une m*****
Non c'est fini ? Ah tu te trompes une fois t'es mort !
On va refaire, m'en bats les steaks! On va faire bien mieux !!! On va faire bien mieux !
Loneliness , Game of Thrones
Pfff... Please
Stanley Kubrick moins c'est sûr , Guiness
euuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuuh, moins...
Ohh c'était... attend que 100 000 d'écart , c'est fourbe !
Ok sex position *rire bizarre*
ah y a du cul. non mais je me dis mettre 'Adèle' face à 'position sexuelle' c'est un peu chelou.
est-ce que y a plus de gens qui veulent écouter des chansons d'Adèle
ou est-ce qu y a plus de gens qui voudraient savoir comment faire l'amour bizarrement
non ils n'oseraient pas : moins *soulagement*
'converse'  moins que 'nicki minaj'
oh puta** c'était quand même beaucoup. 'wikileaks' est une organisation gouvernementale
fondée par julien -nin- qui a pour objectif de publier des documents ainsi que des analyses politiques et sociales
à l'échelle du monde oh ! Ouais mais les gens préfèrent acheter des converse
OHLALA quelle théorie de folie ! Alors Google vous êtes où ? Mais où êtes vous ?
'racisme'. Bien plus que 65.000
puta** bien plus euh attention hein ! 'online poker' bah plus
y a masse gens qui jouent à ça
tu vois google
je sais qu'à comploter sur ce coup-là
ME MENS PAS !  Tes assassins ils devront passer par cette porte
pour m'atteindre tu sais avec quoi j'vais les attendre bâtard ? *sort un nerf*
PAH ! Il est décédé
"reggae vs paypal" oh beaucoup de gens veulent se connecter à paypal je pense WOH
"friends" c'est culte de ouf mais c'est vieux bon quand même plus
OUI Allez !
"samsung galxy s6" bien plus OUI !
perdre du poids
oh puta** ça touche tellement de gens plus que 6 millions ? Oh puta**!
Ouais
D'accord, je me suis tellement humilié google ils oont même plus besoin d'envoyer un assassin là c'est fini. Snapchat ah bah là on atteint
on atteint un truc. "ISIS" non pu**** pas mal quand même "Sons of
Anarchy" c'est une série de fou c'est sûr
voilà, vive la moto
Jim Carrey, moins hélas
ufo, je suis sûr y en à un max y a tellement de gens paranos NON NON j'me suis trompé
j'aimerais bien faire comme toi mon cher Barack Obama mais faudrait au moins que j fasse un score d'au moins 40
e cigarette alors ça,  alors ça !!
tu crois j'vois pas clair dans ton p'tit jeu google
ça c'est moi dans 10 minutes si ça continue
Iphone 6s bah alors là...
lord of the rings oh moins de 9 millions ouais ouais beaucoup moins
après entre l'anneau du seigneur des anneaux et l'iphone j'prends l'anneau hein
"Syria" A mon avis y en a beaucoup. Ouais on dépasse largement. Pink Floyd oh c'est de la musique
et en plus c'est culte. On met plus ou pas ?
oh c'est pareil ! Vous avez voulu me piéger c'est ça
"5 star hotels" Oh ça il doit y en avoir à mort
oh david fincher c'est quand même bien stylé il fait des putains de films, Gone Girl, tout ça
allez plus
pokémon alors là ! OUI!
allez ! *aïe*
yorkshire terrier ? bah moins
mais non mais  t es sérieux ? Ce truc là vous intéresse  6 fois plus que de la bouffe ?
mais y a un problème dans votre tête !!
J'avoue j'suis juste frusté parce que j'ai perdu
Jeremy Clarkson
bah tu fais pas plus que "Jurassik Park" j'suis désolé mais pas mal quand même hein mais
le féminisme ça fait plus que
ça ou pas, je sais pas si ils tapent ce mot là directement
non ça fait moins je pense
ouais ok "Budweiser" c'est de la bière calmez-vous
putain c'était pareil ohlala. Des cours
de conduite est-ce que ça fait plus que d'la bière ?
Bah nan ! on boit de la bière plus qu'on ne veut des leçons de conduite !
Bah oui !
A là vôtre hein !
Netflix, alors là alors là...
POOOOO !!
Perte de poids, on avait dit plus hein !
(les résultats apparaissent)
(Il chante)
Red Hot Chili Peppers, bah alors là, allez allez allez, faites péter
alors je veux qu'au cours des 4 prochaines années, ce chiffre soit multiplié par 100 000
(il chante)
FUCK ! Bière c'est plus que le NSA, oui.  Canabis c'est plus que la bière
Oui, cocaine c'est moins que le canabis, calmez-vous...
Apple, c'est plus !
Mark zuckerberg c'est moins, tetris, c'est moins
Porn, alors là, alors là ça y va ! Ah pour consommer des films de cul, y'a du monde, hein !
les gens tapent moins pauvreté que twerking quand même, sur google
c'est bien, on se rend compte de pas mal de truc je trouve, avec ce site
ok là on est en bon chemin, on est à la moitié de notre meilleur score
Facepalm, PLUS PLUS! J'suis con !!
Nan c'est bon, j'suis pas con, c'était fait exprès. Est-ce qu'y a plus de gens qui tapent liposuccion que de gens qui tapent hôtel de luxe ?
ben déjà c'est les mêmes personnes qui tapent ça *RIRE*
hein sinon tu peux taper ça par curiosité
ah putain nan...
on est à 10 mec, on est à 10
attention Google, est ce que c'est la défaite pour vous
ok 12 PS4 boh fait péter ! kristen stewart est ce qu'elle fait plus
oh put*** mais non mais elle fait pas plus mec
tu tapes jamais kristen stewart
tu tapes twilight pour voir twilight
du coup on s'en fout
y a 2.700.000 personnes qui veulent voir la vie de cette meuf
sur google chaque mois put***
j en peux plus ça fait une heure d'façon vos chiffres ils sont truqués
j'suis un rageux. Merci à vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo n'hésitez pas à aimer la vidéo si ça vous a plus moi j'me tire j'en ai marre
google faites attention vous êtes  pas à l'abri que j'me pointe rue de londres
avec mon pistolet hein
puta** même le bruit est nul
ça ne fait peur à personne